[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans face
aux territoires sur tv5 monde en direct
et vous le savez et dans 200 pays et en
14 langues et bien entendu en france ce
matin en direct sur l'antenne de tv5
monde avec nos partenaires dans cette
émission de ouest france de nice matin
de france antilles de la montagne et de
20 minutes vous pouvez retrouver
évidemment cette interview deux m'ont
invité ce matin sur le site les sites
internet de nos partenaires m'ont invité
ce matin c'est hubert védrine bonjour
hubert védrine vous êtes ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères vous avez été en
fonction du quai d'orsay près de cinq
ans vous êtes également président de
l'institut françois mitterrand et vous
êtes spécialiste de géopolitique bien
sûr vous publier deux livres que l'on
voit à l'écran actuellement une vision
du monde dans la collection bouquins et
dictionnaire amoureux de la géopolitique
gens parler chez plon on y reviendra
tout au long de cette émission
évidemment on verra sur toutes ces
questions avec une première question
pour vous ce matin est ce que l'exigence
de poutine d'un paiement du gaz russe en
roubles qui est considéré comme une
rupture de contrat selon les allemands
va encore j'allais dire accentuer les
positions et va encore compliquer la
donne
oui on est dans cette tragédie atroce
qui est cette guerre en ukraine sur la
base d'une décision aberrante de poutine
tragique pour les ukrainiens mais
tragique pour la russie aussi on est
encore dans les cyclades donc ça fait
partie de l'engrenage
provocation de poutine répond ce
champion mais les allemands raisons
selon vous les réseaux les allemands ont
raison de rappeler qu'ils peuvent pas se
passer du gaz
pour l'année en france à raison dans ce
qu'il fait il est tout à fait logique
ans les anciens des sanctions les
appliquera une entreprise peut pas se
substituer en revanche sur le pétrole je
pense qu'il y aura cette semaine à
bruxelles et à beaucoup de réunions un
durcissement sur le pétrole la sphère
des rooms et aaron va pas le traiter ça
comme ça c'est une décision collective à
mon avis de l'ensemble des utilisateurs
du pétrole ou du gaz russe pour la
france les entreprises françaises
doivent elles continuer leur commerce
avec la russie tant que vladimir poutine
est à la tête du pays alors j'ai répondu
une seconde c'est que c'est pas aux
entreprises de décider
il ya des sanctions ne les applique y a
pas de sanctions ils ont pas laissé les
chefs d'entreprise ont ils la légitimité
de dire bah écoutez ça met en péril mon
entreprise donc la suite de son
développement n'ont pas la légitimité de
décider à la place des gouvernements
c'est pas eux qui décident les sanctions
donc il ya des sanctions ils doivent les
appliquer si les appliquent pas ici une
solution est légal dans lequel l'état
est actionnaire est ce que ça complique
la donne encore faut voir au cas par cas
on peut pas répondre globalement ça
dépend de chaque entreprise de ce
qu'elle fait est ce que des
substitutions possible mais l'est il n'y
a pas eu de décision collective en
occident d'adopter n'importe quel
champion qui d'ailleurs n'arrête pas la
galère voyez c'est plus lent le
processus des sanctions avec des
pénalisations et des contre effets sur
nos économies il faut équilibrer les
deux les dirigeants des démocraties
doivent tenir compte des deux aspects
monsieur choc n'a pas tort de fait
remarquer qu'il a besoin du gaz russe
que l'économie allemande ne peut pas
fonctionner sans ça donc on va pas jusqu
ici on n'a pas été ce cas là jusqu'à
l'embargo encore moins jusqu'à la guerre
donc il faut que les occidentaux mais
européen les occidentaux d'un alpha
c'est une agression aussi terrible que
la sphère d'ukraine adoptent des mesures
tenable faut pas non plus prendre des
mesures parce qu'ils ont dit tous
épouvantés par les images des
bombardements les indiscriminée qui
touchent des hôpitaux des maternités des
centres commerciaux mais il faut prendre
des mesures qui soit tenable dans la
durée faut pas d adopter aujourd'hui
pour y renoncer dans trois mois mais
parce que nos sociétés seraient au bord
de l'écroulement envoyée il ya un
équilibre à trouver pour les pour les
responsables hubert védrine ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères est
l'invité de face aux territoires ce
matin dans un instant françois-xavier
l'offrant de ouest france sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour françoise et guy lefrand il est
le rédacteur en chef de ouest france le
premier quotidien en langue française au
monde et nous allons parler avec vous
évidemment de deux de ses confrères
d'ukraine bien sûr avec la naïveté des
européens bonjour monsieur védrine une
guerre c'est pas un conflit c'est une
guerre il faut prononcer le mot vous
étiez à nantes il ya quelques jours vous
avez utilisé une formule que tout le
monde comprend vous avez dit voilà les
européens croyait vivre au pays des
bisounours et ils se rendent compte
qu'ils vivent dans un pays qui est
plutôt jurassic park heures tout le
monde comprend la référence c'est un
monde effectivement très cruel qu'est ce
que voulait dire qu'est ce que vous
reprochez à l'europe alors été aussi
naïf que cela mais il d'abord je parle
pas spécialement de l'attitude envers
comptines ci ne remarque plus générale
que je fais depuis 20 ans 25 ans en état
d'esprit des zorra n'est pas l'esprit
après la fin de l'union soviétique donc
l'après date c'est pas la sphère du mur
en selle à faire de la f1 de murs 20 91
les occidentaux en général on dit on a
gagné
fin de l'histoire demokrasi marché nos
valeurs universelles on a gagné aux
états unis ça prend une forme de
puissance hyperpuissance c'est ma
formule de l'époque est rude et des
dialogues tout à fait étonnant et
stimulant que mon ami que je salue ici
madeleine albright
une vraie amie même pas un poids sain et
chez les européens ça prend une forme
plus naïve en dise on est dans un monde
post it riposte identitaire post
tragique et nos valeurs vont régner dans
le monde ça ça c'était quand même une
illusion liés à la mondialisation
heureuse et 10 à la propagation de nos
valeurs liées à l'économie globale de
marché l'idéologie omc c'est tout ça que
j'avais caractérisée comme une vision de
bisounours à l'époque il n'y a pas que
moi moi je suis un français typique mais
le ministre allemand sigmar gabriel
disait attention nous sommes des
herbivores géopolitique dans un monde de
carnivores géopolitique mais c'était il
ya 15 ans c'est donc remonter au début
cela n'est pas lié à la guerre en
ukraine maintenant il faut remonter au
début de l'ère poutine
légale si nos débuts nancy 20 de lurs le
début de la russie et ensuite l'arrivée
de poutine oui c'est là qu'on n'a pas
bien pris conscience de ce qui se
passait sans doute alors je sais que
c'est très difficile de parler de ces
débats aujourd'hui lors qu'elle est bon
mais il recycle urgences et le cessez le
feu mais il n'empêche que les grands
américains les vétérans de la guerre
froide qui avait combattu lui toute leur
vie était totalement anti communiste ils
ont presque tous étaient opposés
l'élargissement de l'otan les kissingen
origines ski kenan matelote wertheimer
des gens comme ça donc c'est pas un
débat franco français des dernières
années alors parlons de la des fenêtres
jusqu'à demain moment on reviendra
parlant de la défense justement donc
l'allemagne a annoncé un investissement
en matière de défense de plus de 100
milliards 100 milliards d'euros est
légal au delà de 2% de son pib est-ce
que sur la question la défense l'europe
n'a pas été naïve on a l'impression que
la défense européenne on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que c'est une affaire dont
il a d'ailleurs l'europe est défendu par
l'otan ça c'est à la demande des
européens depuis l'après-guerre ce n'a
pas changé l'alliance atlantique de 49
aucun pays européen ne veuille y
renoncer ils sont inquiets à linverse
comme un président américain comme
preuves mais émet des doutes et si 30
des terres il a jamais une question de
défense européens et les français
intelligemment très bien sait très bien
ce que propose le plan macro depuis des
années mais les autres européens disent
il faut pas qu'on aille trop loin parce
que ce serait un prétexte pour les
américains pour nous abandonner donc
quelles sont les raisons financières il
ya des musées non c'est vrai nom c'est
mental comme on dit chez les sportifs
les européens ne veulent pas avoir
assumé seul la question de la défense et
averses café poutine il a réveillé le
temps pour le moment il a réveillé le
lisant la volonté allemande de se
défendre de quoi il y aura une vraie
armée allemande le requin n'avait plus
en réalité peut-être que prenant macron
va réussir à canaliser ce sursaut dire
quelque chose d' européen d'une sorte de
ma vie liées aux biens dans l'alliance
peut-être avec des signes très bien avec
des si on peut refaire le monde mais si
demain trump été réélu est-ce que ou un
trompe un treuil les ordres d'un haut
noirs barrés ce que les européens ne
doivent pas aussi penser à leur défense
peut-être demain sans l'amérique
les aucun européen pense à un aucun ça
c'est un débat pour franco français sont
les meilleurs on estime merrill et oui
mais même le général de gaulle n'a
jamais quitté l'alliance il avait quitté
à la longue l'otan parce qu'ils étaient
contraints n'est pas d'alliance pas
l'alliance donc il faut arrêter de rêver
aucun pays européen ne lâcher mais seuls
pour l'europe la défense si coûteuse
c'est dangereux c'est terrible et c'est
donc il faudrait garder la protection
américaine mais on peut peut-être
sous cette alliance
développer une affirmation repris avec
des capacités avec des forces qui a pas
de matelas après faudra savoir qui
décide quoi mais il ya un chemin entre
les deux camps même mouillé alors donné
les européens vont par renoncer à
l'annoncé ma mère ce qui se passe si le
réveil de l'otan auquel nous assistons
pour le moment bien sûr qu'il n'est plus
en mort cérébrale non voilà est-ce que
vous estimez que la réaction justement
de l'union européenne américain a été à
la hauteur c'est une réaction très
spectaculaire cholet champion oui mais
il faut comme je lisais un instant que
les sanctions seules de nabeul faut pas
adopter sous l'effet des d'une émotion
archi légitime mois des images elle
brosse en prenant des mesures qui sont
intenables d'un point de vue social
économique démocratique parce qu'après
il y aura des votes à peu près partout
et les les pays européens tiendront
pendant que se tenait dans la durée même
si ça entraîne mais c'est de la faute de
poutine pas de la nôtre une sorte de
désagrégation de ce qui a été la
mobilisation globale qui va régler tes
non pas être atomisé en petits morceaux
mais différents grands blocs et un jour
ou l'autre d'entre eux sortir du système
de sanction mais bon ça c'est après
après demain alors la situation
militaire en ukraine et complexe on a
l'impression que même s'il faut pas
aller trop vite que les troupes russes
sont pour le moins ralenti laquelle
s'enlisent les russes sont sont
évidemment les plus les plus forts quand
on regarde le
matériel militaire l'armement
mais on a l'impression quand même que
que la réaction ukrainienne est
extrêmement extrêmement forte et assez
efficace comment voyez la suite est ce
que vous pensez qu'il va y avoir un
enlisement comment comment comment vous
voyez les choses il est clair déjà que
l'armée russe s'est donc poutine n'a pas
atteint l'objectif qui était mettre la
main sur l'ukraine à 2008 est changé le
gouvernement à qui a fait s'est il ya
une résistance acharnée dj craignait
qu'il faut saluer c'est une crème
grouille d'armes antichars et c'est bon
on est au moment à mon avis le plus
dangereux parce que poutine devant ceux
relatifs enlisement peu décidé
d'escalader d'employer des armes de
jahier l'a empli les armes hypersonique
pour impressionner il parle du nucléaire
bon je crois pas à cette hypothèse vous
n'y croyez pas non mais c'est pour
impressionner les dons les populations
d'europe de l'ouest qui alarme chimique
et a faim il ya plusieurs possibilités à
trausse d'escaladé il si l'élargissement
poutine étant coincé il pourrait décider
de l'attaqué sur un aérodrome en pologne
ou ailleurs où il y aurait des armes
pour l'ukraine pour voir si le temps
réagit vraiment ou pas les grandes
missions historiques apprendre de la
part de l'ensemble des dirigeants des
pays de l'alliance en commençant par les
états unis bien sûr sur qu'est-ce qu'on
fait par rapport à ça on est dans ce
moment là puis en même temps peut pas
complètement écarter l'hypothèse que
dans quelques jours poutine commence à
parler comme s'il avait atteint son
objectif est que le président ukrainien
qui est d'un courage extraordinaire
nextradio disent moi je suis prêt à
accepter la neutralité et l'abandon de
la clim est cet art c'est parce que je
veux sauver l'ukraine vous ne croyez pas
un problème intérieur moment tout à fait
vertigineux - quand il peut aller dans
un sens ou dans l'autre non vous n'aurez
pas aux problèmes intérieurs que
pourrait avoir poutine ben c'est pas une
question de croyance j'en sais rien mais
il me semble que des décideurs dans ces
vauriens tout le monde le chouette et
personne ne peut le démontrer bien sûr
il ya des millions de russes pour pas
dire plus des dizaines de millions qui
sont épouvantés par la décision qui a
été prise qui en gros crois un peu comme
poutine sur l'histoire le rôle de
l'ukraine deux cafetiers dramé qui sont
absolument opposés à la guerre qui sont
dévastés par des conséquences pour eux
sur la guerre sans parler des familles
où il ya déjà des des gamins russes qui
ont été envoyés là bas sur la base d'un
mensonge qui se retourne une guerre
fratricide avec des slaves donc il ya
forcément un effet dans la société russe
de la sq et ça remonte un système de
décision que tout le monde décrit comme
étant concentrés sur poutine seul et
peut-être de trois personnes elles mêmes
intoxiqué qu'il aime un faute s'étant
aggravée par la pandémie non je vois pas
encore ce processus aboutir et je
reviens la question du mal et même
rythme je reviens la question du
nucléaire oui il cherche à impressionner
oui à nous impressionner et apparemment
ça marche beaucoup de gens sont
impressionnés par ce qu'ils se disaient
vous dites je n'y crois pas du tout non
j'y crois pas tout court pourquoi n'y
croyais pas mais j'en sais rien je peux
pas le démontrer mais je ne crois pas
que poutine veulent se suicider voilà je
peux qui veut enclencher un engrenage
nucléaire incontrôlable après les
conséquences pour le pour tous ceux qui
seraient concernés notamment dans la
zone européenne mais je peux pas le
démontrer ici d'une réflexion à voix
haute alors justement on parle de
vladimir poutine veut qu'on l'empêchent
pas de mettre la main sur l'icann en
tout cas de la neutraliser jusqu'où on
verra quel gouvernement à kiev on verra
déjà il n'a pas atteint les premiers jo
pistes pour ça que je crains dans les
jours qui viennent l'escaladent quarts
deux têtes que ça va partir dans une
autre direction justement parle de
vladimir poutine que le prix normal
qu'on a raison il a raison de garder le
compte de garder contact dialoguer pour
le plaisir de dialoguer mais essayer de
garder le contact une bergerie au moment
où ce sera utile évidemment on parle de
vladimir poutine est justement show
nuque et dessinateur collaborateur de
ouest-france régulier à une question à
vous poser sous forme de dessin elle
concerne la dîme et robotique dont les
gouttes
hubert védrine vous fûtes ministre des
affaires étrangères à un moment crucial
de notre histoire qui a fracturé notre
relation avec le monde cela je veux
parler du bombardement de belgrade par
l'otan en 1999
la serbie est dans la petite soeur de la
russie alors vladimir poutine disait
celui qui ne regrette pas l'urss n'a pas
de coeur
celui qui souhaite son retour n'a pas de
tête par la question que je pose c'est
vladimir poutine est il un affectif qui
s'ignorent ou un malade mental qui
s'ignorent aussi
c'est trop facile de me traiter de
malades les dirigeants qui sont aux
antipodes de nos conceptions de
pathologistes et les analyses s'est
séparé sans eux ça c'est plus compliqué
que ça mais dans la sphère du kosovo à
laquelle il fait allusion où j'étais me
laisser le groupe de contact des
ministres qui ont géré la faire pendant
18 mois on avait négocié avec milosevic
pour que ils arrêtent ils n'ont pas le
génocide mais les exactions au kosovo
est finalement confié groupe a conclu qu
on n'y arrivait pas ce que me le sait
vite s'ils comprenaient rien bloquer
tout on a demandé à l'otan ce pas le
temps qu'a décidé de demander le temps
de frapper sur le l'armée serbe et les
russes se sont retirés du groupe de
contact à ce moment là mais on est sûr
medvedev à l'époque on n'est pas souple
et inondé après les deux mandats pts et
après quand les bombardements obtenu que
milosevic dit ok j'accepte le compromis
le ministre russe de l'époque igor
ivanoff est revenu dans le groupe de
contact il en a rédigé ensemble la
résolution 12 144 qui permettait de
gérer la sortie de la faire changer
dépendance du kosovo c'est dire qu'à un
moment donné on pouvait être du lourd
dans la défense de deux intérêts de la
sécurité et quand même garder comme
pendant la guerre froide un contact avec
la russie c'est absolument incompatible
françois-xavier lefranc la une de ouest
france or là une nouvelle france allait
consacrer aux entreprises françaises qui
sont en russie qui ont investi en russie
et elle est également consacré au réveil
des européens du réveil face à la guerre
parce que c'était effectivement une
guerre au coeur de mercy françois-xavier
lefranc rédacteur en chef de ouest
france le plus grand quotidien
francophone du monde croit que ces six
ans et quelques journalistes 606 120 600
analystes et une soixantaine de
correspondants dans le monde merci à
bobino monde le journal
remarquable journal dans un instant nous
accueillons un autre journaliste de
ouest france patrice moyon sur ce
plateau merci pour ce que vous avez le
franc
[Musique]
bonjour patrice vaillant vous êtes
journaliste à ouest france je
l'indiquais vous êtes spécialiste de
l'économie et dans un instant nous
allons interviewer red green sur les
conséquences de cette guerre notamment
pour la france entame économique tout de
suite emile et aux frais depuis brive
hubert védrine qui représente cette
semaine notre partenaire centre france
la montagne à une question à vous poser
sur les dialogues avec poutine ne
regarde bonjour à tous bonjour monsieur
védrine vous avez toujours plaidé pour
le maintien du dialogue avec vladimir
poutine une stratégie suivie aujourd'hui
par emmanuel macron selon vous qu
apporte ce dialogue un mois après le
début des frappes russe sur l'ukraine
comment dialoguons avec un chef d'état à
la personnalité aussi insaisissable qui
ne semble écouter que lui-même et qu'est
ce qui selon vous pourrait l'amener à
cesser cette guerre
alors pour le moment c'est de ne rien
mais l'ensemble des dirigeants
occidentaux
comptent beaucoup sur le brillant macron
pour maintenir ce lien il s'agit pas ce
qu'il fait d'ailleurs il a faim il
fallait il a du mérite parce que rim et
yonne ça peut pas obtenir un résultat
dans l'immédiat si c'était le cas
poutine n'aurait pas attaqué il y aurait
déjà un compromis etc il faudrait
revenir à ce qui aurait dû être fait il
ya dix quinze ans sur la sphère de
l'ukraine donc le dialogue c'est pas par
plaisir de dialoguer mais je voudrais
rappeler que même pendant la guerre
froide face in union soviétique encore
plus armée plus dangereuse plus
menaçante qui faisaient assassiner
beaucoup plus de gens nous ce que ne le
fait la russie même dans cette époque
tous les grands dirigeants américains
ont maintenu le dialogue les dialogues
mais pas pour encore soit pas pour le
plaisir mais pour faire entrer des
arguments pour contenir peut-être les
attaques pour préparer des compromis si
cela donc c'est une nécessité de
sécurité pour le moment ça n'a pas donné
de résultat mise peut que demain dans
dix jours dans trois mois ce sera un
élément décisif
monsieur védrine justement je voudrais
revenir sur la guerre en ukraine et les
conséquences économiques vaud me iweins
qui s'est exprimé hier devant les
parlementaires français il a accusé
notamment un certain nombre
d'entreprises françaises un auchan
leroy-merlin renault dès que les
sponsors de la machine de guerre russe
est-ce qu'il a raison de demander le
départ de ces entreprises françaises de
russie je ne pense pas mais je voudrais
dire en même temps que je l admire il un
courage formidable ready inattendue de
la part de gens qui l'avaient choisi
estimait compte tenu du fait que c'était
un comédien avant mais bon pourquoi pas
reagan aussi est un comédien la
d'origine et donc il est formidable il
dit ce qu'il a à dire dans la position
où il est mais c'est pas une bonne
solution de se mettre à boycotter
l'ensemble du monde russes et il est
bien pour son pays il est bien il défend
les intérêts des courageux mais ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut que toutes les
entreprises mondiales quitte la russie
faut penser à l'avenir à la presse après
après demain c'est difficile maintenant
sous les bombes avec les images
horribles il n'empêche qu'un jour ou
l'autre il faudra revenir à la question
comment on fait pour coexister pour
cohabiter que la russie est à côté alors
concrètement et le marine en macro je
crois savoir à encourager des
entreprises françaises sauf quand il ya
des sanctions soient là il faut les
appliquer il faut appliquer la loi a
plutôt rester quand c'est possible et
concrètement est ce que le russe
derrière y'a pas que poutine yahia le
peuple russe bien sûr mais est ce que
concrètement puisque valide puisque
poutine menace de de saisir les actifs
des entreprises qui veut française qui
partiraient trop si sk pas une menace
que la chine finalement tire les marrons
du feu de ce conflit
non mais c'est à dire que que j'ai
bricolé que les actifs au soir du les
uns qui soit saisie et que évident et
éventuellement des emplois sur 12 mois
depuis son pass de charybde en scylla en
gros toute façon toute la vision naïve
qu'on a eue sur la mondialisation
après le triomphe occidentale des années
90 soit à travers nos valeurs
universelles soit à travers la pensée
omc on voit bien que ça marche ça marche
pas et sur le plan économique ça va
n'ont pas éclaté en petits morceaux mais
se réorganiser autour d'une zone
americano atlantic une la question à toi
ça pourrait devenir avec la chine c'est
est ce que ça pourrait être pire avec la
chine c'est un potiche déjà entamés
parce que ça fait déjà trois présidents
américains qui essaient de désamour iq
et leur économie de l'économie chinoise
donc c'est déjà en cours chaîne que la
chine en profite au passage pour
racheter à bas prix le pétrole oui c'est
que la russie ne pourra plus exporter
oui c'est d'ailleurs cette bonne guerre
si je peux dire faut s'y attendre faut
pas dit surpris par sa donc chaque
acteur chaque grand acteur du monde il
va pas appliquer l'idéologie
américano globalisé dérégulé
financiarisé tu sais ça c'est une
période déterminée mes amis ne vous dans
votre question est fondée ça va se
passer comme ça oui oui vous dites qu'il
faut prescrire les guerres économiques
mais est ce que finalement les sanctions
du simple maintenant j'ai pas oublier le
terme non j'ai dit c'est une guerre en
ukraine a simplement un conflit ou une
crise mais j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait
mener la guerre économique est un peu
plus russe d'iam faut trouver
l'équilibré donc bruno le maire il a
fait une erreur en disant oui mais il a
dit autre chose après il a reconnu que
c'était une expression d' approprié
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que les
sanctions aient pu les sanctions
économiques sont pas la meilleure façon
de de faire céder poutine le faire céder
immédiatement non sinon la guerre serait
arrêtée tout de suite s'excuser les
sanctions les plus dures qu'on ait bâti
après celle embargo de blocus la guerre
bon donc je dis pas qu'on a d'autres
solutions les occidentaux veulent pas
entrer en guerre aucun parlement dans
une démocratie aujourd'hui dans les pays
de l'alliance de votre et la guerre bon
donc il faut quand même faire quelque
chose d'où les sanctions et après en
même temps les sanctions il ya un
travail pour les ajuster de façon à ce
qu'elles pénalisent pas plus les les
pays les sociétés occidentales que la
russie qui déjà depuis quelques années a
appris à s'autonomiser dans certains
domaines il ya plein d'exportateurs
français qui ont perdu des parts de
marché on est des fromages fins il ya
d'autres choses que ça donc on est entre
les deux c'est pas noir et blanc c'est
plus compliqué que ça
à noter mais on est aussi loin que
possible pour le moment dans les
champions ça va être durci sur la fière
du pétrole pas de gaz ce qu'on a un
dossier de dire si le par l'allemagne à
tout à l'heure c'est que vous donnez des
satisfécits régulier à ce que fait
entreprend emmanuel macron oui mais les
autres aussi je trouve que les
dirigeants occidentaux font bien mais
comme et emmanuel macron été attaqué sur
le fait de maintenir le dialogue alors
qu'il le fait à la demande et avec
l'accord de tous les dirigeants
occidentaux d'après ce que je sais donc
choses absurdes de l'attaqué parce qu'il
n'y aurait pas eu de miracle au bout de
trois coups de fil est-ce que total à
raison de maintenir sa présence en
russie écoutez moi j'ai vu
l'argumentation de de total mais chez
paulhanais dis-je applique les sanctions
point il ya des sanctions j'ai zappé il
qu'elle n'a pas j'ai pas les appliquer à
la trace des gouvernements berger vu
qu'il avait fait une annonce pour
réduire la part d' achats de pétrole
voyez par rapport à 200 da védrine et
d'autres invités ce matin l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères en
direct sur tv5 monde armelle le goff qui
est la directrice de la rédaction de 20
minutes à une question à vous poser
justement sur volodymyr zelensky
bonjour hiver védrine que pensez-vous du
combat des valeurs qui se joue
actuellement entre l'ukraine et la
russie
combat de valeur habilement mise en
scène par le président ukrainien
notamment hier lorsqu'il est intervenu
rey devant les députés de l'assemblée
nationale et député français de
l'assemblée nationale encore une fois je
redis mon admiration nous l'avait dit
pour cet homme comme incroyablement
courageuse ollier dans les libraires
viewer bon mais en même temps
il n'y a pas de solution sur la base des
valeurs donc si on veut à tout prix
transformer ça en guerre de religion est
ce que c'est ça les valeurs en fait
c'est insoluble c'est insoluble
donc je trouve que le terrain de la
géopolitique même s'il est froid et dur
il permet d'imaginer a tout de suite une
sorte de
d'apaisement de cessez le feu
d'arrangements de bric et de broc et un
jour peut-être une solution plus durable
michel riesen en termes de valeur je dis
ça aux occidentaux très convaincu très
motivés très engagé il ya quand même une
grande partie du monde aujourd'hui et
qui dit que non seulement c'est ce que
je dis moi les occidentaux ont perdu le
monopole de la puissance d'un bulletin
de paul mais beaucoup d'autres notamment
en asie disent non c'est la fin de la
parenthèse occidentale la fin de la
parenthèse occidental qui a duré trois
quatre siècles y compris sur le fait que
nos valeurs à nous sont universels donc
quand on entend les chinois d'hygiène
particulières ciel et l'autre qui l'est
pas et puis on a nos propres valeurs les
occidentaux sur la fois choqué révulsés
et très inquiet par ça mais on va devoir
vivre dans ce monde dans lesquels on n'a
plus la capacité qu'on a eu pendant
quelques siècles on a fait un bon ou
mauvais usage d'autres sujets dont qui
je crois pas que le terrain des valeurs
on peut la fois le saluer mais je crois
pas que cette donne naissance à un
processus de solution très vite la
dernière question le plan proposé par la
commission européenne pour s'affranchir
du gaz russe à l'horizon 2027 au moins
cette année des deux tiers est ce que ça
vous semble une bonne réponse ça me
semble une réaction normale dans les
situations où on est mais je crois pas
qu'ils choix réaliste on y était me dont
les capacités de production de transport
de stockage mais l'orientation viendrait
ce qui pourrait être le plus important
toute façon si elle encore que plus que
social questions écologiques donc il
devient un plan non pas pour combattre
le nucléaire de façon obsessionnelle et
bornés ignorant de ce plan scientifique
mais combattre le charbon réduire le
charbon puis le pétrole puis le gaz et
c'est notoire de lima
le fait que si on ne fait rien dans
quelques générations d'ici là la planète
et plus habitable de ses récentes c'est
difficile à dire aujourd'hui compte tenu
de l'émotion sur l'ukraine mais ça reste
fondamental ça donc le plan oui c'est
une réponse momentanée conjoncturel
c'est très bien si la commission disait
qu'en même temps il faut relancer le
nucléaire entre temps parce qu'on n'a
pas d'autre solution et les siens de vie
renouvelables sont loin d'être
suffisamment productives et à bon marché
pour remplacer l'ensemble voyez faut pas
oublier les sept autres plans merci
patrice moyon hubert védrine l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères est
notre invité politique ce matin sur tv5
monde dans un instant des maîtres
korkmaz de tv5 monde sur ce plateau
merci
[Musique]
bonjour démette dans un instant nous
allons aborder les questions
internationales toujours avec hubert
védrine mais denis carot qu'est le
directeur des rédactions du groupe nice
matin notre partenaire dans cette
émission à une question à vous poser on
l'écoutent hébert védrine il est dans
son studio de télévision à nice en
duplex
bonjour hubert védrine la france a rendu
hommage dimanche aux victimes des
attentats de toulouse et montauban en
2012 ici à nice nous restons
profondément marqué par les attentats de
la promenade des anglais et de la
basilique notre dame est ce que vous
estimez que la lutte contre le
terrorisme est suffisamment efficace en
france aujourd'hui et ne voyez vous pas
un risque particulier à la libération
dans les prochains mois de plusieurs
dizaines de détenus condamnés pour
islamisme
alors en ce qui me concerne j'ai une
conception pas franco française sur le
sujet j'ai beaucoup d'amis maghrébins ou
égyptiens ou autre avec lequel je parle
de ces questions depuis toujours de ma
vie et tout cela sont favorables à une
alliance entre les musulmans en général
et les démocrates pour isoler pour
réduire l'influencé des fondamentalistes
traditionnels issus surtout de la micro
micro minorité terroriste n'oublions pas
que l'immense majorité des victimes du
terrorisme islamique sont des musulmans
parce que c'est là où il attaque en
premier parce que les musulmans veulent
pas appliquer la charia redéfini par les
les examine aujourd'hui donc c'est ça le
cadre général après il ya le cas
particulier de la france mais aussi de
la belgique mais aussi de l'italie ou de
l'espagne on est des victimes
collatérales le choeur l'affrontement
est au sein du monde musulman sunnite on
n'est pas le coeur des trucs et sa speed
ça s'écoute pas par des raisons sociales
ou au tout politique de la ville si
c'est pas ça le coeur du sujet il faut
le traiter donc part à mon avis par une
alliance général comme comme je lé
indiqué et après on tombe sur des
chiffres très très précis surtout qu'il
ya eu quand même un déni ou un
aveuglement sur la violence islamiste
par les réseaux tout ça il faut en effet
je ne sais pas je peux pas répondre à la
plata ministre de la justice en exercice
qui auraient toutes les données il
faudrait dans l'idéal sur un suivi très
très vigilant de l'ensemble de ceux qui
sortent
qui sans doute n'ont pas changé dans
leur tête je sais pas si c'est faisable
donc je pardonne des délétions comme ça
c'est moi j'étais au coeur du power 20
ans donc je suis très compréhensif par
rapport aux gens qui ont à gouverner en
vrai vous parliez de la parenthèse
occidental est ce qu on peut l'appliquer
aussi cette parenthèse occidentale au
sel c'est pas ma thèse je sais bien mais
puisqu'on parle de cette mise en retrait
un peu est-ce que ça aussi peut
expliquer la situation au sahel a
empêché les jo de ceux qui combattent
l'occident dans votre règne est terminé
on peut plus imposer vos normes une
illustration aussi au sahel par exemple
celle c'est un peu différent parce que
il me semble que quand il ya eu la
menace sur bamako françois hollande a eu
raison était courageux de prendre la
décision d'intervenir à la demande du
des maliens et des pays africains
voisins et du conseil de sécurité ce
n'est pas une lubie françafricain non
c'est aujourd'hui le contexte est
différent il faut rappeler le début
quand même allez-y parce que non mais
j'avais fait allez il faut le rappeler
parce que sinon les gens mélangent tout
alors maintenant les maliens ne veulent
pas que la france reste dans son vin les
nigériens n'ont plus dont le burkina
faso dont no no no no l'ensemble des
autres voudraient que la france reste
mais ils ont failli pharma janvier eh
ben c'est à définir justement celui-ci
mais la france peut pas se substituer au
temps la france pouvait grâce aux
landais l'armée française la
constitution du général de gaulle
bloquer l'offensive sur bamako mais la
france n'est pas seule lutter contre le
djihadisme dans l'ensemble du sel qui
est plus grand que l'europe c'est
absurde non on n'a pas été non plus pour
combattre les russes fournir à l'origine
nos morts ne sont pas morts pour rien
dans cette affaire mais si les autres
pays du sahel veulent qu'on reste il
faut qu'ils le demandent clairement pour
le moment on indique que les bases pour
le moment il n'y a aucun pays à ma
connaissance ici à peu près tous les
autres en dehors du mali vaudrait que la
france reste mais il faut voir comment
on est petit on peut pas faire le job à
leur place par rapport à ça et après il
faut qu'ils s'arrangent eu avec le mali
parce que l'évolution malienne peut les
empêcher eux de lutter contre le risque
de dialyse dans leur propre pays
le responsable de quoi que ce soit dans
cette affaire sur c'est sur ce terrain
là la russie a aussi joué
rôle en sous marin c'est le cas de le
dire avec la force de la glère par
exemple est ce que là aussi on a pâti de
cette
offensive russe sur ce terrain là mais
moi j'ai tiré conneries s'en fiche de ça
les maliens vol s'acoquine avec les
russes grand bien leur fasse celle de
l'arrivée plusieurs fois depuis
l'indépendance ça les a pas empêchés de
jamais être capable de régler le
problème des relations avec le nord-est
du mali dont idem sur la guinée donc oui
la russie pousse ses pions dans quelques
pays comme ça mais il faut pas non plus
exagérer on reconnaît surestimé la
capacité de l'armée russe poutine le
premier il s'était gorée on surestime la
capacité des forces hagner oui je
pencherais une hausse non on surestime
les effets pervers de leur présence
est-ce que ça va entraîner les disputes
entre wagner et les différents pays
africains et c'est vraiment il y
obligeront à gérer ceux ci sont appelées
piller le mali je ne sais pas pourquoi
ils sont là mais en tout cas les
gouvernements les ont appelées à mon
avis c'est énorme et c'est leurs
problèmes leurs problèmes il faut qu'on
redéfinisse de façon saine c'est qu'on
fait ou pas meilleure dans cette partie
de l'afrique ce n'est pas tout la flic
sur la base de la demande des
gouvernements africains qui sont
indépendants depuis des dizaines
d'années quand même pas de ce qu'ils
veulent ou pain au vu du contexte
ukrainien est ce que il n'ya pas aussi
un problème avec le droit international
qui n'est plus respectée est-ce que ce
droit international il est toujours
valide au vu des transgressions aidé
d'un poutine qui fait valser
le droit international mais il était
respecté quand le droit international
c'est une espérance et donc est ce que
ça veut dire que les institutions
internationales ne sont donc maintenant
on sait très bien que des institutions
pour que tous les pays se parler travail
entre eux bon même si par exemple dans
l'onu l'ue et de trop ils sont pas unis
les nations bon c'est bien qu'ils aient
des lieux des institutions et le droit
international c'est une espérance c'est
une une perspective où il ya lesquels il
faut travailler mais ça ne marche que si
les protagonistes sont déterminés à
l'appliquer et le les violations du
droit de jeunes y en a il y en a des
dizaines des 10 donc il n'ya pas de
droit international respecté week est
une sorte de d'armes et de marc scheer
et qui imposait tout le monde le
respectait pas sur le climat on va être
obligés un peu non en le climat c'est
différent c'est une réaction collective
et donc jean faudra lui droit
international non mais c'est là il y a
le droit aussi à la traduction de l'aveu
de la prise de conscience et de la
volonté politique mais après c'est
surtout une question de mutations
industrielles technologiques
scientifiques et c'est finalement
juridique les pins la base aujourd'hui
la diplomatie classique conventionnelle
est ce qu'elle est aussi toujours
adéquate mais elle n'a pas été inventé
depuis des siècles ou parler que des
copains diplomatie s'était inventé il ya
longtemps maintenant pour voir pas la
paix avec ses amis ses autres - oui
puissant faisceau sierra si on veut mais
ça sert à rien ça a été inventé depuis
longtemps pour parler à des ennemis
redoutables côté des gens qui vous
haïssent peut-être des gens qui veulent
nous détruire donc ya pas de
contradiction la diplomatie c'est pas
faire des parlottes s'est négociée
négocier
aujourd'hui par exemple toujours plus
aujourd'hui ni les américains ni les
européens n'ont établi par exemple de
liste de lignes rouges est ce que la
ligne rouge ça c'est autre chose c'est
pas la diplomatie quel animal si c'est
la négociation voyez ligne rouge voulait
dire sur l'ukraine absolument par ex il
y en a une c'est le temps l'article 5
qui est pour le moment un putin me
touche pas l'ukraine n'est pas dans le
temps peut-être fallu mettre plus créé
dans le temps avec des garanties bon
merci produits de toucher un pays de
l'otan norma loy s'applique si touche un
pays de l'otan ça veut dire qu'à une
concertation instantanée de l'ensemble
des dirigeants des pays de l'alliance à
commencer par les états unis et les
puissances militaires qui compte d'un
a340 qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce qu'on fait donc ces petites
lignes rouges n'a pas été il n'y a pas
besoin de la proclamer c'est l'ambiance
ce soir mais effectivement si poutine ne
cesse de tester les européens et les
occidentaux il ne fait pas il veut m il
veut re russie fier du créneau par
ailleurs c'est un test je match ça peut
aller plus loin par exemple on n'a pas
cru les américains quand ils ont dit à
l'automne dernier qu'il pouvait que les
russes s'apprêtait à envahir
l'ukraine est ce que là encore on
commence mais c'est encore possible
comme les américains avaient beaucoup
menti sur l'irak et beaucoup de gens qui
ont dit peut-être qu'ils se trompent là
dessus et en plus tout le monde savait
qu'il y avait un plan de franchise entre
autres mais jamais autre plan
la ligne rouge elle existe c'est
l'article 5 et puis aller au delà ce
soit une décision à prendre
démocratiquement hubert védrine est
notre invité cyril gautier le directeur
éditorial de france antilles notre
partenaire à une question à vous poser
depuis fort-de-france on écoute
bonjour hubert védrine face à la
contestation et aux violences en corse
le gouvernement a rapidement évoqué la
question de l'autonomie du territoire
tout comme il avait évoqué cette
question de l'autonomie en guadeloupe
lors de la crise sociale du mois de
novembre dernier autonomy d'ailleurs
dont on n'entend plus parler aujourd'hui
dans le territoire en guadeloupe pensez
vous que ce soit la bonne solution qu'il
faille
face à cette contestation évoqué des
questions de changements de statut pour
ces territoires que ce soit la corse où
les territoires d'outre-mer
je vais vous décevoir mais je par
principe je ne prends pas position sur
des questions de politique intérieure au
meilleur sens de notre sens le plus
noble du terme y compris les
institutions y compris l'organisation
des territoires y compris l'autonomie
donc j'ai pas d'éléments et après je
dirais simplement que qu'est ce qu'on
met dans l'autonomie oui mais qu'est ce
qu'on met en plus comment marchent les
le budget financement qui demandent quoi
bon mais c'est pas à moi de décider tout
seul sur en fonction et je représente
que moi c'est pas moi de décider ce
qu'elles genre d'autonomie il faut
accepter de discuter dans tel ou tel cas
hubert védrine j'ai une question pour
vous sur le rôle que joue que va jouer
l'allemagne la puissante valmagne
maintenant aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'était pas une énorme erreur de là de
françois mitterrand vous étiez son
conseiller à l'époque de ne pas se
montrer favorable à la réunification de
l'allemagne rétroactivement et c'est
totalement faux ce que vous dites c'est
moi je pose la question non mais
pourquoi vous poser une question aussi
fond parce que je vois l'allemagne
devenir cette puissance mais sur
mitterrand aujourd'hui le stade où j'ai
regardé à l'époque les déclarations de
françois mitterrand avant la
réunification ou à une santé qu'il faut
qu'il freinait et qui n'était pas non
ils voulaient tous les observateurs
indépendants ont constaté les
observateurs mais pas les historiens il
n'y a pas un seul historien français ou
allemand qui dit ça aujourd'hui
françois mitterrand très tôt donc les
observateurs se sont trompés sur
l'attitude qu'on prêtait à françois
mitterrand les commentateurs à l'époque
en général c'était des sortes de
militants qui voulaient à battre
l'allemagne de l'est qui considérait que
c'était une victoire de l'occident et
que le simple fait de poser des
conditions normales pour que la
réunification le moment venu se passe
bien c'était déjà insupportable mais
c'est une vision vraiment de l'époque
est totalement contestable et jean n'a
pas le temps là mais je peux vous donner
15 livres français ou allemand qui
explique autrement depuis l'origine mi
temps avait agi pour que la
réunification se passe bien qu'ils aient
des élections que l'allemagne confirme
le renoncement aux armes abc que helmut
kohl confirme l'engagement dans la
monnaie unique et ça c'est le détail de
ce qui s'est passé en 89/90 qui aboutit
à un résultat formidable la vinification
été très bien gérée dans la relation
entre kohl et mitterrand s'il y avait un
millième de vrai dans les commentaires
des journalistes excité de l'époque
serez briser la relation mitterrand kohl
or elle était extraordinaire encore plus
extrême dire après qu'avant voilà alors
est-ce qu'il avait eu
votre autre question c'est qu'est ce qui
va se passer que l'allemagne maintenant
pour le moment poutine a obtenu la fin
du pacifisme allemand l'allemagne de se
doter d'une armée alors qu'elle avait
disparu en pratique garder mais c'est
dans l'otan et dans le temps une
dernière question plus politique hubert
védrine vous êtes président de
l'institut françois mitterrand vous vous
considérez comme socialiste toujours
mais ça n'a pas de rapport si moi
j'étais mitterrand bien un coq
mitterrandien et l'instituteur c1 une
fondation et travaille sur l'histoire
est la même quelle est l'opinion vous
avez la campagne dalida par exemple rien
j'ai pas d'opinion sur la campagne
électorale je ne suis pas là pour ça et
je m'abstiens de tout commentaire sur
ses dimensions politique
une vision du monde elle exclut hubert
védrine une comment dirais-je un retour
à des valeurs que française on voit dans
cette élection présidentielle que
beaucoup de candidats veulent replier la
france sur elle même sur beaucoup de
beaucoup de points est ce que est ce que
cette vision du monde c'est le titre de
votre livre collection bouquins elle aux
problèmes faut pas confondre
l'attachement des peuples alors
l'identité il ya aucun peuple au monde
et qui a envie d'être dissous dans le
magma mondialistes aucun c'est pas
forcément du repliement c'est tout à
fait compatible avec l'échangé
l'ouverture la circulation etc faut pas
mélanger les deux mais qu'il est le
peuple qui est avide de renoncer à ce
qui laisse son histoire achats langue à
la façon dont il se représente son
propre passé de mon dessin des des
palestiniens ou des israéliens question
au niveau des iraniens ou des rues où
vous achèterez faut pas mélanger les
deux voiliers vous appellerait à voter
emmanuel macron je suis pas là pour
parler politique
intérieure ni pour par les élections
mais franchement ce qu'il fait à l'heure
actuelle dans la gestion de cette
horrible affaire ukrainienne est le
maintien
bon alors c'est très très très
n'arriverez pas à dire que vous ne
mangez pas au rabelais qu'ils allient
fait le relais parce que je comprends
pas ce genre d'émission mission de
politique intérieure je suis pas là pour
ça pour prendre des positions qui peu
importe ce que je dis sur l'éviction en
revanche je pense qu'il fait le job
remarquablement
courageusement et que j'espère que à la
fin des fins un moment donné on verra
qui aura été utile pour enclencher un
début de solution on n'en est pas là
celle sur l'ukraine merci hubert védrine
ancien ministre des affaires étrangères
de nous avoir consacré ce temps de
direct sur tv5 monde merci dé m korkmaz
on se retrouve évidemment jeudi prochain
les programmes continus sur la chaîne
envoie à tous merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]